- Nobody saw those movies, right?
Because nobody says,
"Honey, let's look through
the TV Guide thing,
"and see if there's any wonderful things
about racism,
(Dave laughs)
"or any things about diversity."
I really...
- Yeah.
You know what I'd like
at the end of the day?
Is a really great diversity humor, right?
There isn't any.
(bright music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and joining me today,
is an American playwright,
a filmmaker whose works
included "Glengarry Glen Ross,
"The Verdict, Wag the Dog," and more.
And author of the new book, "Recessional:
"The Death of Free Speech and
the Cost of a Free Lunch,"
I've got a copy in my hand right now,
David Mamet, welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thanks so much, glad to be here.
- I've wanted to talk to
you for quite some time.
And I was going through
the book this morning,
and I thought, man,
this guy sees the world
sort of as I see the world.
So why don't we do a little 101 first,
for people that aren't
that familiar with ya.
What got you into playwriting,
writing screenplays?
Did you always have something to say
and wanted to put the pen to paper?
- Well, yeah, I was raised as a smartass,
and everyone always said when I was a kid,
"Nobody likes a smartass,"
but I didn't find that to be true
because I always made jokes,
and I always dramatized.
My mother used to say, (chuckles)
"David, why must you
dramatize everything?"
But because that's what I, you know,
I was born with that gene,
just like Sandy Koufax was
born to throw the fastball.
And because that worked,
I never did anything else.
I would never do any school work.
And I worked at a million menial jobs.
We'd call them entry level jobs now,
we called them menial jobs then.
But when I realized there was
this thing called the theater,
and that I could actually get in there
and have the most fun in the
world, I was never coming out.
And that's the thing that
I see about young people,
whatever they're going into,
if they discover something,
for example, aviation, or
they discover the theater,
they discover the military.
If it's in their DNA,
they say, "You can kill me,
"but you're gonna have to kill
me 'cause I'm never leaving."
So that's how I was about theater.
So I started writing plays
when I was very young,
and got from there into
writing and directing movies.
And the rest is, you know, there it is.
- Yeah, so I do wanna jump
into the movies a little bit,
but let's start with the book because
your defense of free speech,
but really beyond free speech,
your defense of America
and your explanation
of sort of this very strange
pivotal moment that we're in,
where we're either about to continue,
or maybe reinvent it perhaps,
or just let the whole thing
go, I think is really apropos.
It's what I'm thinking about a lot.
It's what I'm talking about
on my show all the time.
When did you really start realizing
something was wrong here?
- Well, I wrote a book about 20 years ago,
called, "The Secret
Knowledge," a political book.
And it was looking at
what happened in New York,
and was happening in the theater,
and what was happening...
I grew up as a red diaper baby, right?
My dad was a labor lawyer.
And everybody we knew,
the more radical people
were the communists,
but in our thing, they were all
first generation immigrants.
They just wanted to make a
living and they were Liberals.
And what Liberal meant then,
was give some money to the NAACP, NAACP,
and put your kid in a
Episcopal reformed temple.
And they'd all fought
in the Second World War.
So everybody loved America,
but America to them meant do
your job, raise your kids,
don't get in the other guy's way,
exhibit a little tolerance if you can,
and try to take care of yourself.
Although at that time, and again, now,
we Jews were a despised race.
When I was a kid, there was
still restricted hotels,
didn't accept Jews, clubs that didn't.
They were very open about
it, no Hebrews need apply.
Professions that didn't accept Jews.
And so, like as Jews down
for the last 2,000 years,
we said, "Well, okay,
I can figure this out.
"I'll keep my head down,
and I hope nobody kills me."
And so I was born right after,
two years after they
were throwing my people,
our people into ovens.
So that's the world that we
grew up in, that I grew up in.
And I discovered, first of
all, my Jewish identity.
And I said, "Wait a
second, I'm at Jew," right?
"Was a great people, we don't
have to keep our head down."
I wanted discover what
it means to be a Jew.
So I started studying
the Torah and I said,
"Okay, there's two things.
"One, there is Yiddishkeit," right?
The idea of the Eastern
Jewish, the Ashkenazi heritage,
where all my people came from,
you know, which was Broadway
and Upper Broadway in New York,
and gefilte fish, and speaking
a little bit of Yiddish,
and blah, blah, blah, very good.
But the Nazis, the
Germans destroyed there,
it doesn't exist anymore.
It still existed when I was a kid
because there were the immigrant
generation and their kids,
it was my parents,
and they're gone now.
And so that civilization is just,
the magnificent 1,000-year-long
very rich civilization
of the Eastern European Jews is gone.
But the thing which is
not gone is the Torah.
And so I started studying the
Torah, and reading the Torah.
And I said, "Oh my god,
"this is a record of human experience.
"It's told in story form."
But we Jews tell everything
in a story form, right?
That's how we communicate
with each other, right?
And I realized, I said,
"They said that the German humor
"is all based on the bathroom,
"and French humor is all
based on the bedroom,
"but Jewish humor is
all based on the mind."
It's based on ambiguity, incredible,
inbred adoration of ambiguity.
And the Torah takes it
down to the bare bones.
And it says, "Wait a second,
"here's something you aren't
gonna understand," right?
"Why did God create the snake?
Why did God, the first act
that human beings performed,
first off, Eve
turns her back on God.
And then, the first
act that Adam performs,
the first thing that a human man says is,
he blames his wife, he rats her out.
He says, "The woman made me do it."
So if you read through the Torah,
time and time again, you
say, "I just don't get this.
"I wanna make sense of this."
It's not how to do this and
you'll be a good person.
It's things which are shocking.
So when I grew up, everybody was,
all the Jews were about
Buddhism and Zen Buddhism.
And what the sound of
one hand is clapping,
and the Zen koans.
Well, okay, very good, indeed.
But everything in the Torah
is a provocative koan.
It just doesn't make sense
until you have to look at it,
and look at it, and figure
out what did it mean?
And when you figure it out,
you realize it's all about human nature,
which means about my nature,
that everything in the
Torah is about betrayal,
and incest, and adultery,
and bastardy, and murder.
And that's who we are, that
we're incredibly flawed.
So I took that study and that
understanding of the world,
and to tried to apply it to
the world that I see around me.
I said, "Wait a second,
how did we end up here?"
So the answer is not, the
Democrats took us here, right?
Which they did.
Or that the Marxists have
come out of the woodwork.
Or that the, which they have,
or that the press has,
has imploded upon itself.
The answer is something different,
that these things that occurred
to me are not the cost,
but they're the result.
So they're the result of what?
They're the result of a
certain point in civilization.
And so if you look at
the Torah, that point is,
it's perfectly clear, the Tower of Babel.
Because the richest people in the world,
what do they wanna do?
They wanted raise a tower to
Heaven so they can be like God.
And it all came tumbling down around them.
So I say, "Okay, I get it."
What's Green Peace trying to do?
They're trying to raise,
what's the ACLU trying to do?
They're trying to raise a tower to God
so they can be like God,
so they can be in charge of the world.
So I started to see the world
in a very, very different way.
And so I said, "What
brought us to this point?"
Well, the same thing that
brought the Tower of Babel,
it was prosperity.
I realized that the billionaires'
children don't work.
And when the boss stops
being the assistant
and becomes the boss,
he forgets how to use
the Xerox machine, right?
And he doesn't put his gas in his car.
And he doesn't mow his own lawn.
And he's not connected
to anything around him.
So what happens to this rich person?
They become frightened.
They surround themselves with security.
And they know themselves
to be a flawed human being,
but they forget, they say, "Wait a second.
"I'm like a God, there's
nothing that I can't buy.
"There's nothing that I can't do.
"I'm the richest country in the world.
"I don't have to work.
"Oh, Americans won't do stoop labor,
"we'll open the borders," right?
"I don't have to defend myself, ha-ha,
"because we all really
want the same things."
So as soon as you say,
"It's geopolitical,"
"we all really want the same things,"
some other guy over there is gonna say,
"These guys are suckers, I'm
gonna take advantage of 'em,"
that's the history of the world.
That's what we see now.
- So with all of that in mind, I mean,
that's very much what you're
talking about in the book,
so do you think there is a
rebirth of people realizing
some of this related to either
the Bible or age-old stories
versus sort of the purely
secularism on steroids
that we seem to be stuck in at the moment?
- Well, I don't think it's a rebirth.
I think it's there all the time.
Half of the country anyway,
voted for Donald Trump.
These people, and you know who it is?
It's what happens when the
people become too prosperous,
is the country divides, any country,
into the rich and the powerful, and then,
the parasites who live off
of the rich and the powerful,
wanna supplant them.
For example, Black Lives
Matter, you know, and the Squad,
and the poor who are
getting bribed to stay poor,
which is what we see in the other cities.
But the people who have
always been America
have been the middle class, right?
Been the doctor, the lawyer,
the butcher, the baker,
the candlestick maker, the shoemaker,
because they have to deal with each other.
They have to deal with the supply system.
They have to deal with customers.
They have to deal with credit.
The rich don't have to deal
with any of those things,
and neither do the poor.
So the middle class is very,
very connected to each other,
but the middle class is
vanishing, vanishing, vanishing.
And especially with the,
with A, with the
centralization of distribution,
and then, with outsourcing
everything to China.
So, but there's still a middle class,
and it's basically in the South, right?
Because the South is the last vestiges
of the wonderful heritage
of agrarianism, right?
And the farmer is, Harry Truman, said,
"The farmer is the
smartest guy in the world,"
'cause he's sitting on his
tractor 12 hours a day.
And he's thinking about the weather,
and about the railroads,
and about the credit,
and about the price of grain, and about...
The farmer realizes that every
moment he spends on task A,
he can't spend on task B, right?
Which is Tom Sowell, right?
And which is Hayek, and
which is Milton Friedman.
It goes back to, you
know, John Stuart, no.
You only have so much energy.
If you spend it on A,
you can't spend it on B.
So I also realized that the most,
all pilots are conservative, right?
'Cause the pilots realize,
"I just have so much gas.
"I can spend that on A
or I can spend it on B,
"but I know--"
- I mean,
you can't just make it up.
I thought we could just
print money, make up gas.
You can't do that?
- Exactly so.
You can't spend it twice.
So Friedman says price just indicates
the way that we get together to say,
I'm not gonna ask you how
hard you worked for the money.
And you're not gonna ask me
how hard I worked on the shoes.
We agree on a price, we'll do business.
But if everything becomes centralized,
we're no longer doing
business with each other.
The rich and the poor both
look for ways to gain power.
So the Black Lives Matter,
and Antifa, and the Squad,
and blah, blah, and the
teachers' unions, right?
And the service unions
say, "Fuck it," you know?
"Okay, I know how to gain power.
"Power comes through unity,
power comes through strength."
Well, okay, to a certain extent, yes.
There's something in the labor movement.
But on the other hand,
that's fascism, right?
It's that nobody has
to take responsibility
because they're all part of the fascia,
they're all part of the group.
And the rich say, "Yeah,
fuck it, I don't care.
"Raise taxes, I don't care.
"I'll stay here, 180 days in
the Republic of Santa Monica.
"And then, I'll go to a low tax state."
So what happens?
The rich having despoiled
California, Oregon,
Washington, blah, blah, blah, New Mexico,
go to a low tax state and
take the virus with them.
They didn't cause it, they're like a,
forgive my being blunt,
they're like a pimple.
Something's un-right,
you don't get the pimple
because your skin is upset.
You get a pimple because
your metabolism is upset.
Right? Your blood is.
So I realized that to say,
"Biden, and Kamala Harris,
"and all those guys,
look what they've done?"
They're just opportunists.
That's all that they are.
This is an absolutely predictable
point in human history.
And it's up to us to decide, okay,
what would we like to have happen?
And let's see if we can bring it about.
- Yeah, and that really
is what the book is about.
I do wanna say for the record,
as a Californian refugee,
who just moved here to Florida,
I came here for the right
reasons to do the right things.
So I will keep this place
as free as Florida has always been.
You're in LA still, you are in LA still.
Anyone that listened to the
last few minutes it is going,
"Wait a minute, how is this
guy in Hollywood, in LA,
"saying these things, how
can you make a living still?
"How can you get gigs?"
Can you walk into CAA and
they're gonna still talk to you?
I mean, how has that been for you?
- Well, as we used to say in Chicago,
I drove my car here, I
didn't come on a bus.
So I've continued to
have a pretty wonderful
God-given career as a playwright.
They're doing my plays
all around the world.
In fact, they gotta play now on Broadway
with Lawrence Fishburne, and
Sam Rockwell, and Darren Criss,
an older play of mine
called, "American Buffalo."
And as far as getting hired
in the movie business,
I'm too old to sit in a room
with 12 guys named Jason.
(Dave laughs)
- You know my agent?
They're all named Jason.
(laughing) But how bout that?
I mean, just living in LA right now.
I mean, after two years
of COVID and just the way,
the whole industry has collapsed.
I mean, that was one of the reasons,
there were many reasons
I left LA.
- Yeah.
- But it was also that there was,
it wasn't just the COVID
craziness and everything,
and the crime, and the homelessness,
okay, we could do all that.
It was just that it felt that there was
nothing cool about it anymore.
Whatever was cool and creative about LA
felt completely gone to me.
- Well, cities grow for a reason.
And when the reason is
gone, they get repurposed.
When I was first working in
New York a million years ago,
I was working in Greenwich Village.
And anything south of
Houston Street was a slum,
absolute slum.
There were people who were
squatters, who were artists,
and homeless people living in those lofts.
That used to be a manufacturing district.
And eventually, the city came in and said,
"Okay, okay, you artists,
you can live here forever.
"We'll call it 200 bucks
a month, you can rent."
So I got friends whose
grandchildren are living in lofts
for 200 bucks a month that
would sell for $30 million.
Okay, so now, what used to be lofts
and manufacturing becomes artists.
So as always, along with
our brothers, the homeless,
the Bohemians come in and
repurpose a neighborhood.
And because the Bohemians come in
and repurpose a neighborhood,
then, the restaurants come,
then, the shops come, so now, SoHo becomes
the prime shopping
district on the East Coast.
And people come from all over
the world to shop in SoHo.
It gets repurposed, right?
What happens then?
Black Lives Matter, and
the rioters come in,
and say, "Fuck you."
They (laughs) clean everything out.
And what does the New
York police do about it?
Nothing.
- Not much, yeah.
- So what you see is,
what started off as an industry
catering to the shipping
trade in New York,
then, became abandoned, and then,
became a place for squatters,
both the homeless and the artists,
and then, became a shopping district,
and is now going, yet again,
going to become a slum.
So this is the history of the world.
- So how do you liken that to LA?
What do you think is gonna happen to LA?
And I do have to tell you that every time
I mention California on
my show gratuitously,
I have to put $5 into this jar.
And at the end of the year,
I'm givin' a couple 1,000 bucks away
to someone who lives
California to move to Florida.
So if you're lookin' to move,
I might have a couple 1,000 for ya.
What do you think is gonna happen to LA?
- Well, first I wanna say about Miami is,
I used to go to Miami all the
time in the 50s with my dad,
who had business down
there, we'd fly down there.
And I'm still trying to get the zinc oxide
(Dave laughs)
off my nose.
What's gonna happen--
- Yeah, it's sunny.
but it's all right.
(David laughs)
- What's gonna happen to
LA? It's happened to LA.
Here's the thing.
Just as there's no
business like no business,
there's no, when you do
away with the theaters,
and you do away the possibility
of independent production,
there's no reason for the
film industry anymore,
to be in LA.
I mean, they came out here
because there was a sunshine.
And they made a bunch of crap, every year,
they made a bunch of crap,
and a couple of movies
that were memorable,
and a couple of people snuck through
and made something beautiful.
And a couple of people snuck
through and made a fortune.
And sometimes, the two
people were the same.
And sometimes that they weren't.
But the industry grew up here
first because it was sunny.
And second, because they were,
they were fleeing the Edison Company,
which held the patents in New York.
So the bootleggers came
out here to make movies.
So the studios, just like SoHo,
grew up around these bootleggers, right?
And then, that gave rise
to this incredibly magnificent community.
They had 5,000 people
working as musicians,
and sent the are kids to
graduate school here, right?
10,000 people working as actors,
all of the professions and so forth,
were a middle class that
supported the film industry.
But as films became more
and more successful,
they became more and more expensive.
And so any film that you see,
when I first started making movies,
my producer, a guy who taught
me about movie-making said,
"Any movie can be made for any price.
"You can make the $100
million movie for $5 million.
In fact, today with an iPhone,
you can make it for 50 grand.
And you can make the 50 grand
movie for a hundred million.
So people are making comedies,
which is two people
standing in a stupid room,
talking to each other, for $200 million,
it doesn't make any sense.
So what happens, because
they have so much energy,
and so much money to distribute,
what happens is that
it attracts parasites.
Just like, if you are rich, you say,
"Well, I have a
housekeeper, how about that?
"Oh, I'm richer, I have two housekeepers.
"Oops, gotta keep an eye on them.
"I'm gonna have a household manager.
"Oops, gotta keep an eye on them
"because they have friends,
I'm gonna get security.
"Oops, now I'm gonna get a..."
So eventually,
the super structure brings
down the ship, right?
There's more super,
there's more restaurant critics
than cooks or customers.
So there's no reason for the
business to be here anymore.
In fact, most of it isn't,
but yet, we have these huge,
like you mentioned CAA,
people who, if they all went away,
nothing would change
in the movie business.
But they spawn other parasites, right?
The agent gets a subagent,
and the subagent gets a blah, blah, blah.
And then, people get a manager
to deal with the agent.
No one's ever exposed what a manager,
(Dave laughs)
told me what a manager does.
So there's all of this super structure,
but there's, but who's working?
Right?
- I am proud to say
that I've never had a manager.
I have agents, I'm still not
totally sure what they all do,
but I've never had a manager
'cause that one was well beyond me.
- Yeah, no, the job of the agent
is you give 'em 10% to say,
"Geeze, I tried everybody,
I did the best I could."
- Yeah, I get him the deal, he takes 10%,
and then, I sign something,
it's pretty good.
Pretty good gig.
- That's right.
- But so do you think, so what
are you doing there still?
I mean, if you feel this about LA,
I asked this to all of my LA friends,
which is why I'm asking you, I
mean, most have left already,
but what's gonna come of this place?
- Well, it's dead.
I mean, for example,
I started looking in New York
many years ago, 40 years ago,
they started putting up the,
I saw it first in Chicago.
They started putting up the nicknames
of the streets on the street signs.
I grew up in Chicago,
State Street, State Street,
all of a sudden it's State
Street, That Great Street.
Go to New York, Broadway, Broadway,
Broadway, The Great White Way.
Well, when they start
putting up the nicknames
on the street sign,
what you're saying is
guess what used to be here?
Right?
- Something that it ain't.
- Something that's not there anymore.
So in Martha's Vineyard, and Cape Cod,
and Nantucket when I was a kid,
I had friends in the East who were,
their parents were professionals.
They were doctors, lawyers,
Indian chiefs, blah, blah, blah.
And they had a place that they rented
on those outliers, right?
And I started making a
little bit money in my 20s,
and my friend said,
"Why don't you buy a place
over there on the ocean?
"There's nothing between you and Portugal.
"It's goin' for nothing."
So I say, "Yeah, no, yeah, no, yeah, no."
So now, those places are selling
for 50 and a $100 million,
but you're not gonna find
anybody who makes harpoons
on Martha's Vineyard,
which used to be a
whaling port, it's gone.
Right?
- Yeah.
- So that Soho and and
Chelsea, where I used to live,
was where the ships'
chandlers lived when New York
was originally one of the
great seaports of the world.
And when I was a kid working there,
it was the capital of the world.
But you can't be the cultural capital
of the world without artists, right?
And the reason that
the cities existed was,
you took disparate elements,
which would never, ever meet in life.
For example, in Chicago,
a woman wrote a book
about 20 years ago called,
"Terrible Honesty"
about Harlem in the 20s.
She said, "You have these three groups
"that are completely scorned,
"and they have their
own wonderful cultures,
"Black America, gay America,
and Jewish America," right?
But they all met in Harlem,
and they met in Broadway,
and they cross-pollinated each other.
It was incredible energy,
but now, were completely
separate in the city.
I mean, I go into my
neighborhood restaurant
of Santa Monica.
I said that the definition of
diversity is someone who has
10.1% body fat.
(Dave laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, they
destroyed Santa Monica,
the Promenade, the whole
thing, they destroyed it.
- Yeah, no, it's, you know,
the diversity is somebody
who hasn't had Botox.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- So there's no
cross-pollinization anymore.
And what happened to free
speech is the Democrats
and the Republicans don't even
speak to each other anymore.
Those who used to meet at
the synagogue, at the church,
at their kids' baseball game... (laughing)
She's a Black woman and a
white guy across the street,
met with a baseball game.
And she was talking to her kids,
her Black kids about something or other.
And he said, "Excuse me, you shouldn't,"
white guy says to her, "Excuse me,
"you shouldn't talk to your
kids that way about racism."
(David laughing)
- That's...
- She's sayin',
she's saying to their kids,
"Racism, there is no,"
he said, "Racism is all gone.
"Get out there and play, big deal."
And he... (laughing)
- That's white woke 101, right there.
So what do you think
Hollywood can produce?
I mean, do you see anything sort of new
and inspirational coming
out of that machine?
We're shooting, we're
taping this right now,
just a couple days after the Oscars,
which I realized that I didn't
even know the Oscars were on.
Of course I found out because of the slap
heard round the world.
But then, when I went
through the Best Movie list,
and I went through a
bunch of the other lists,
I did it live on the show,
I think I had seen one of the films.
I flipped through Netflix
and Hulu and it's very hard
to find something that feels new,
or original.
- Yeah.
- Or inspirational, that the machinery,
because of the reasons
you're talking about,
the Hollywood machinery
seems unable to give us,
or maybe can occasionally choke
out something new and fresh,
but there just doesn't
seem to be anything left.
- Well, there isn't, I mean,
nobody saw those movies, right?
Because nobody says,
"Honey, let's look through
the TV guide thing,
"and see if there's any wonderful things
about racism,
(Dave laughs)
or any things about diversity.
I really...
- Yeah.
You know what I'd like
at the end of a day?
Is a really great diversity humor, right?
There isn't any.
- I like to be lectured
by late night comedians
about how I'm racist
right before I go to bed.
That's my thing.
- Yeah, me too,
(Dave chuckles)
it's terrific.
So the question is who's watching?
And see, when you got a theater,
you know who's watching,
because if they go to sleep
or they leave in the
middle of the first act,
you better change your mind pretty quick.
But when you own the high ground,
there's no connection with the audience.
They say, "Oh, you know what?
"If you wanna see the Weather Channel,
"you're gonna have to
buy this whole package,
"and we'll sell you
whatever crap we want."
So yet again,
it's not that the inmates
have taken over the asylum,
but that they've been kicked out
of the direction of the asylum.
'Cause the inmates of the
asylum were the artists, right?
When you kick the artists
out, they say, "I get it.
"I know how to use the theater,
I know how to use film.
"I'll tell people what life is like,
"that Black people are people too.
"Everyone is people too, accept the Jews,
"and that sick people are
sick, and what they deserve..."
You know, there used to be all these plays
in New York about sick
people, people who are blind,
people who are deaf, blah, blah, blah.
They always won the Pulitzer Prize
for telling us that the bad guy,
doesn't the bad guy realize
that a blind person is a person too?
So you come in humming the play,
but nobody likes that play,
except the Pulitzer Prize Committee.
- What about sort of the
Disneyfication of the theater that,
you know, in the heyday of the theater,
it was all, it's everything
you're talking about.
It was these incredible
independent writers and playwrights
who could come up with original stories.
And now, basically, everything
is a redux of a Disney movie,
either from 50 years ago or
sometimes from three months ago.
- Yeah, well, when I
was a kid in New York,
the Theater District was
a slum, it was dangerous.
It was sex trafficking, and
confidence men, and mugging,
and massage parlors, and
whore houses, and pool halls,
where you can buy anything in
the world, and great theater.
But as the theater brought people to...
Look it, the cause of decay
is always growth, right?
When the growth stops, at some
point, it always has to stop,
decay takes over to, as you know,
as the yogis would say, to
repurpose it for the next thing.
Okay, so the Theater District,
especially 47th street, is all...
When the middle class left New York,
the theater still existed,
but the middle class couldn't
afford to live there.
So the theater, because
it was a money maker,
appealed to tourists.
That's who goes to the
theater, it's all tourists.
So you can't appeal to the tourists
with a new play by a new
guy nobody ever heard of,
on a subject that you
can't reduce to a tagline.
No one's gonna do that because
it costs, whatever it costs,
5 million bucks to stage a play.
So because, so the artists
aren't coming to New York.
Who wants to go do that play?
You know, anybody can write that play.
And I was looking at, it was a really,
they used to have ads on TV,
I used to watch TV years ago.
They said, "Not actors,
real-life people," right?
"The people in this
commercial are not actors.
"They are real-life people."
I realized if you turn it
around, what you say is,
"Yeah, I get it, look good to me.
"Oh, you don't need to
be an actor," right?
So you don't need to be an
actor if there's no scripts,
'cause anybody can say,
"You know, I'm kind of like,
"I don't know, I kind of
look around I kind of say,"
you know, anybody can do that.
Anybody can write that garbage.
Where are the artists gonna grow?
They aren't gonna grow in the cities.
They can't afford to live there, right?
And no one's gonna put on their stuff.
So something else will happen.
- So how do we get out of this thing?
I mean, it's connected to what
the purpose of the book is.
The point of the book
of this pivotal moment,
you know, can we save
this great experiment?
But how do we get out this sort
of culturally, politically,
spiritually, however you wanna take that?
- Well, you're doing it.
- I'm trying to do something.
- Sure, I mean, what...
It's like Golda Meir said,
remember her secret weapon?
Remember what it was?
- I should know this, I should know this.
It was the people, it was the people.
- She said, no, she said
there's no alternative.
Israel is her secret weapon,
there's no alternative, right?
So our secret weapon is
there are no alternative.
So is that gonna mean we're
gonna die at our post?
Yeah, maybe, sure, we're gonna die anyway.
So the question is how do
we wanna spend our lives
in the midst of this vast upheaval?
So for years I thought it was
a huge mistake on the right
for people to say, "Well, if we did this,
"if the Republicans did this,
"I can't believe da, da, da, da, da,"
well, it's time to believe
it now 'cause it's true.
That there's a moment in our country
that something new,
something new has to emerge.
And we're either going to emerge into a,
all civilizations die, we're
gonna emerge, accept the Jews,
which is why people hate us,
we're gonna emerge into
a vigorous maturity,
or we're gonna be taken over
by Russia, China, and Iran.
There you go.
- I suspect you don't think
that the people in charge
at the moment are quite up to the task.
- Well, they aren't in charge.
They're along for the ride.
You know, there's a bunch of...
Politicians, with a couple of exceptions,
are whores, thieves, thugs, and fools.
That's what politicians are.
All of them, with a couple of exceptions.
That's why we have a Constitution,
because the people who
wrote the Constitution
understood that, right?
That they were just regular guys,
and right now, regular
guys and women, right?
And that maybe, they
would abide by the rules.
And because they weren't
gonna abide by the rules,
every couple years, we had to
vote, we had to kick 'em out,
'cause they didn't abide by the rules.
And if they were caught cheating,
lying, whoring, whatever,
the newspapers would rat them out, right?
So newspapers don't do that
anymore, the legacy newspapers.
And if you look at the
politicians who weren't whores,
thieves, thugs, and fools,
what happened to all of 'em?
They killed 'em, right?
Pretty good examples, my
favorite Jew, Jesus, killed him.
Churchill, they threw
him outta office, right?
Saved Western civilization.
They shot Dr. King.
They shot Lincoln.
They took Trump, who only
wanted to do a good job,
and treated him worse
than any other citizen
in this country has ever been treated.
And they're still at it.
So the people who say,
"Wait a second, no, no, no.
"Do not look behind the
curtain," are the left."
And so the right says,
"There's nobody there."
That was what my book was
like, the "Secret Knowledge,"
there isn't any secret knowledge.
There's what does it cost?
Here, here's what politics exists.
It's the post office, the Navy, the Army,
and the Marines, and the
Coast Guard, that's it.
Anything beyond that, you're
gonna attract the whores,
thieves, thugs, and fools.
So Trump comes in, he says,
"Yeah, let's deal with that.
"We'll let everything else go ahead."
They wanna kill him because
he's completely opposed
to the zeitgeist, the spirit
of the time on the left.
So they say, "Oh my God, he said this,
"and he said that about grabbing the girl,
"blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah."
That's bullshit.
That's the same thing as saying
that Jews, they're greasy.
It's finding a reason for your prejudice
that seems to make sense to you.
Or say, "Oh, okay.
"He's got a big mouth and
he sticks his foot in it.
"Therefore, I tell you what,
let's open our borders,
(Dave laughs)
"and give all of our money.
"And start a nuclear war with Iran."
Does that seem like a good idea?
So the people and the conservatives say,
"That's a rotten idea.
"Let's stop it using the
means at our disposal."
The problem is
in any cat fight,
the person screaming the loudest
is probably in the wrong,
'cause the other person is saying,
"Well, okay, I get it,
you're outta your mind.
"Let's abide by the
rules and see if we can
"come to some mutual
agreement," so that's the right.
So that's why the right
gets accused of everything.
- So how do you think
we shift that paradigm?
I'm sure you've heard the phrase,
the Breitbart phrase that,
"politics is downstream from culture."
The right obviously lost culture
over a certain amount of decades.
I think that actually
is shifting right now,
a little bit at least,
but in terms of art and everything else,
is there something better that,
say right-leaning or conservative?
I mean, you described yourself before
as an old-school liberal.
I mean, that's what put me on the map.
I was trying to save
liberalism from the left
five years ago, or seven years ago.
But for any of us that are
roughly freedom-loving,
you just want people to live
and let live kind of people,
what can we do culturally or artistically,
or through the type of work that you do,
to turn this thing around?
'Cause it's not gonna
be the political leaders
that turn it around, obviously.
- Yeah, we can't do anything,
'cause that's not the purpose of art.
Art is the conjunction of inspiration
with an audience,
that the artist has some inspiration.
And that the inspiration is reducible
to be kind to Black people,
or hate white people,
or people dying of cancer
deserve our compassion.
That's not inspiration.
So that's what art is.
Art is
very closely akin to religion.
And it's not at all connected
to politics or culture.
Art, it's like the oyster, right?
The oyster makes the pearl,
but the oyster can't use the pearl.
But other people can use the
pearl, but the oyster can't.
The oyster isn't making that pearl
to influence people to
dress up their honey
when they go out to the nightclub, right?
The oyster has to make the
pearl or it's gonna go nuts.
There's nothing that art can do.
What we can do is speak
the truth to each other,
and not give in.
And not because it's the
daily erosion of life.
I'm gonna tell you my five pronouns,
or wait a second, you
have to identify yourself,
or are you vaccinated,
this constant shepherding
each other day-to-day,
which is killing.
And to be able to deal with
this retail is exhausting.
It has to be dealt with wholesale.
And the way the individual
deals with wholesale,
say, "Thanks, I'm not playing,
I'm not playing that game."
You know, it's like what
we learned from, you know,
I learn it anyway, from gay
friends, gay liberation,
30 years ago, 40 years ago,
"We're here, we're queer,
get used to it," right?
"It's not my problem that I'm gay," right?
"If you've got a problem with
it, that's your problem."
So that's what we have to do,
we have to speak up and say,
"And in fact, we're here,
we're queer, get used to it,"
because then it starts
to crumble a little bit.
When that look on people's
face, you know, you've seen it,
where they say, "Oh my god,
he's not playing my game."
- That actually gets nicely to a phrase
that's in the book that I really loved.
You talk about a "virus of conformity."
And that seems to be it almost
more than anything else,
that the media, the
politicians, the people,
you know, COVID vaxes, gender
pronouns, the whole thing,
that everyone is in on a bunch of stuff
that nobody really believes.
- That's true.
But as Shakespeare, another Jew, said,
"Truth's a bitch that
must be whipped to kennel,
"while Lady the Brach can
sit by the fire and stink."
Lady the Brach means a female dog.
Truth's always a bitch that
must be whipped to kennel.
Okay, here's the thing about religion,
a thing about the Torah is it says,
"Behave in this way and you'll be,
"that's what God wants.
"He wants you to do justice, love mercy,
"and walk humbly with God."
The rest of it is not
in your control, right?
Like they say, like it was
Cicero or somebody who said,
when someone said,
"What do you do when the tyrant says,
"'Do A, B, and C, or I'll kill you?'"
He said, "You say to the tyrant,
"'I never told you I was immortal.'"
So the question is, if
you were given the chance,
if they came to you and they said,
"Okay, here's what I want you to do.
"I need you to recant," right?
"Because, A, if you don't
recant, we're gonna ruin you.
"And if you do recant, we're
gonna make you a billionaire."
Up to you, what are you gonna say?
- Well, A, I would know they're
most likely gonna make
you a slave, actually,
not a billionaire if you do recant,
especially if you're recanting
for something you didn't do.
- Exactly, so, but another
way to look at it is,
I never told you I was immortal.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Are you gonna say that
you're going to ruin me
for not proclaiming that men and women
can turn into each other?
Well, that's up to you, it's not up to me.
What's up to me is my conscience, right?
Now, am I gonna fall off the
wagon and be a coward sometime,
be a fool sometime, and be wishy-washy?
Probably, so what do you do then?
You get back on the wagon.
And you meet the best people
in the world, don't ya?
- You absolutely do.
- Yeah.
- The people that I've met on
the other side of this thing,
it's incomparable
- I know.
- to what I was doing before.
- Incomparable.
- It's like Ruth Wisse at
Harvard, teaching at Harvard.
And teacher comes up to her and says,
"Ruth, you know, I wanna
say, blah, blah, blah.
"But what will happen
if I tell the truth?"
Ruth said, "You'll be free."
So it's better to be free,
it's exhilarating to be free.
And you might as well blow
your fuckin' brains out,
if having seen a little bit of the truth
of our contemporary civilization,
you say, "Yes, but I'm going to conform."
'Cause you're dead then, you're just dead.
- I got one more for ya.
- Yeah.
- What's inspiring you these days?
What do you look at, or see, or hear,
or listen to, or read that you go,
"That's got the thing
that I'm looking for,"
or at least got the spirit of it, maybe?
- I read everything 'cause
that's what I do all day.
Years ago, I was going out to my office.
My oldest daughter was about 10.
She said, "Dad, where you going?"
I said, "I'm going to work."
She said, "Nighty-night,"
'cause that's what I do.
You know, I nap all day and I read,
and every once in a while,
I'll jot something down.
But I discovered some really
great writers in the 20s
who were writing about business.
There's a guy called Jesse Sprague.
And he wrote several
books about, (chuckles)
about the building trades,
and about the wholesalers,
and about credit, and the romances,
romance, what do you call it?
Fictional romances of an
imaginary guy in these trades.
And he takes all of America apart.
And he makes it just fascinating.
The view of the 20s, check
it out, Jesse Sprague,
"The Romance of Credit,"
or "Confessions of a
Building Trades Contractor,"
they're marvelous.
- So I ask you what's inspiring you
and you throw me back 100 years.
That sort of says everything I suppose.
- Well, there's, listen,
Bari Weiss is inspiring me.
You know, Bari started at
University of Austin, Texas.
And she asked me, would I play along.
So I'm gonna play along,
so that's inspiring.
Young people today, like Bari said to me,
"Dave, Dave," she said,
"Don't be a curmudgeon."
So I said, "Oh my god, that's true.
"I gotta stop being a curmudgeon," right?
And saying, "Oh, you know, Grandpa says,
"'When I was young fall, fall, fall.'"
Well, of course that's true.
'Cause the point is not when I was young,
things were better.
Well, of course they were
better 'cause you were young.
But now what? You know,
so what can I contribute?
I'd love to contribute, you know?
What can I contribute to my
magnificent country right now?
Tell the truth the best I can, you know?
And that's it.
- You're speaking my language, man.
David, I've really enjoyed talking to you.
We're gonna link to the book down below.
And I hope you'll come to
the free state of Florida.
I don't know that they're
gonna let me back in LA.
So I don't know that we
could break bread there,
but you're welcome here
in Florida anytime.
- Thank you so much, it's
a pleasure talking to you.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.